what we what we have in mind here is
first each one of these individuals
going to tell you a little bit about
their company sort of three or five
minute summary I don't think of it as an
elevator speech because they've already
gone past that stage all right so
they're not trying to sell you anything
they're trying to do is describe what
they do because these are very different
companies and then we've got a series of
four questions that I'm going to post
the panel and at the end of that time
which I hope will be half an hour maybe
a little longer we will turn it open for
questions so that's what we have in mind
so let me start with ELISA let's say
once you introduce yourself and your
company hi everybody my name is ELISA
rap I am the founder and CEO of bottle
notes comm I was in your shoes from 2003
to 2005 with Pete Flint over here bottle
notes began as a niche ecommerce company
we started as a wine club concept really
where the innovation and the online wine
space we were hoping to achieve and have
achieved is building out a personalized
sommelier service so we deliver wine
tailored to our members personal tastes
using proprietary matching technology
thank Netflix or Pandora of wine as the
company evolved in the first year we fan
our e-commerce platform fan to include
not only wine clubs but corporate
gifting and events because some of our
early adopters said we like this notion
of a personalized sommelier but we'd
like it even more if we could apply it
beyond just ourselves and then in the
end of the second year of existence in
ou7 some of our early adopters came back
to us and said well we love our wish
list the wish list functionality you
have but what we'd really like is to use
that as a registry like we're getting
married and we want to start our
marriage with a new wine cellar so a
light bulb went off in our minds and we
created the first national wine registry
and that we've integrated with wedding
channel comm and so far it's still one
of the only it's the only one of its
nature and we are sure we're gonna be
emulated pretty quickly here but that
means that the e-commerce bottle notes
calm the e-commerce business is
this notion of wine clubs online wine
shop corporate gifts and events and the
first national wine registry and we have
dovetailed in the last three years to
not only include our own
direct-to-consumer distribution channels
but also an indirect distribution
channel so we have five partners and a
few more in the wings for their own
e-commerce wine platforms powered by
bottle notes and that white labeling as
we call it is a great path for growth
it's also equally difficult of a
business as the direct consumer business
so it has pluses and minuses to it and
then in addition to the core
direct-to-consumer business and the
indirect to consumer and business
through partners indirect consumer
channel in the last six months in
particular we relaunched our website and
we did that with a little bit of a mind
eye to what the economy is doing and
also what our consumers wanted and so
bottle notes calm as of November 2008 is
no longer an issue commerce platform
it's actually a destination where
commerce meets community we have the
most trafficked wine Facebook app we're
building out a mobile platform etc etc
and bottle notes comm is not just a
place you go to buy wine but you go to
get wine information both personalized
recommendations as we still have that
patent pending matching technology but
even more community recommendations peer
recommendations celebrity
recommendations and so forth and the
reason we shifted strategically was
because a we found I found at the
company to be a and really do a match a
matching service if you will in the wine
industry to be a wine marketing firm for
wineries and importers and a wine
entertainment and education platform for
consumers and the monetization strategy
was well we can do that and we'll make
money as we move bottles of wine what
we've found is that the body of content
we've created ourselves I wrote a book
this last October called bottle notes
guide to wine around the world Navy sips
blah blah blah we have a wine cyclopædia
we have newsletters and podcast
libraries and such all that content that
we are really using as a customer
retention tool to drive e-commerce
really has a life of its own and the
community has taken on a life of its own
which has been terrific so what we
realize is that that community being the
premier online wine community that will
of course continue to partially monetize
its user base through direct sales is
something we very much still wanted
but the new strategy in the new platform
allows us to also monetize through
advertising revenue and on Monday we'll
be launching something called the daily
sip which any of you all who know daily
candy or Thrillist or urban daddy anyone
heard of those sites yeah
so we're launching the daily sip which
we hope will be the daily candy of wine
to even further push us in that notion
in that direction of the premier online
wine community so that's the that's the
three-minute overview of the business
thank you can you say just a little more
about how you how you specialize the the
wine list I'm assuming you don't start
with DNA unfortunately unlike Pandora we
haven't undertaken the wine Genome
Project yet but I'd love to if I had all
the all the funding in the world God
knows we do that'd be fun um we actually
the the patent is around categorizing
the world of wine into different style
profiles so the innovation is that we
categorize the role each wine into
different style profiles based on its
varietal composition its regional origin
and so forth but the cool part comes in
that human beings who come on our site
whether they're wine club members are
now just community members complete a
personal taste profile not too different
from in some ways at a high level about
what you might hear about Trulia and so
you you come in terms of personalization
of search but you complete a personal
taste profile that can ask questions
such as how do you take your coffee and
tea how much do you salt your foods and
those questions intimate your
sensitivity to bitterness and your
sensitivity to bitterness gives us a
snapshot of your likes and dislikes in
wine and the more wine you rate the more
we hone our understanding of your
preferences so the matching technology
is literally a math engine we're got
people's profiles and wine profiles and
you're making mathematical matches so
it's partly choice but it's also partly
individual characteristics absolutely
yeah interesting Pete tell us a little
bit about your company
okay so Pete Flint co-founder CEO Trulia
we are a website designed to empower
people to make better decisions about
real estate which obviously is kind of
pretty interesting right now we launched
in the summer of 2005 and ever
since then the real-estate market has
gone down and down and down and down
luckily we've grown since then so as a
company we are around 80 people right
now I graduated Lissa said in class of
2005 eighty people we want the largest
with the state websites in the US with
around five million unique monthly users
raids thirty three million dollars in
venture capital from Sequoia and Excel
and angels and and other folks how we
make money so we make money selling ads
to the people within the real estate
industry that's kind of on a display
basis so it's kind of taking the money
that used to be spent in the newspapers
and move into that to where the audience
is which is online so that's it's um
it's a big business there's a huge
business but it's also a tough business
because when you're when your
advertisers are also struggling um it's
difficult to to make money off them but
the proposition is is very compelling so
our product I encourage everyone to go
to websites and spend lots of time and
click on all the ads but if you don't do
that what we do is we have a search
engine for homes to sell probably
database pretty much all the properties
in in the US we have all the data around
real estates and that's price trends
community data profile Democrat brat
demographic profile recent home sells we
have a community which is the largest
real estate community on the web which
is primarily around Q&A and also
blogging an article so people have a
question about what does Obama's housing
stimulus plan mean to me as a veteran
buyer they go in and ask that sort of
questions and that's booming right now
so the community artists think so can
you see how you how you get your
listings yeah so we've we've partnered
pretty much with the real estate
industry so
we have about 95 of the top 100 real
estate companies in the US feed their
listings into us so they give us data
feeds or they come in and enter them on
the site so you know everyone from
Coldwell Banker to local sites like
Allen Pannell so we've gone around and
built those data relationships with
thousands of companies what about
individuals who don't list with a real
estate company we don't really offer
that much service for them it's
primarily around they can use that
services but it's primarily around that
the real estate agents and brokers
okay Darrin I'm Darrin Buxbaum I'm the
co-founder and CEO of hourglass
Technologies hourglass is a medical
device company and we're developing a
safer incisionless alternative to
obesity surgery so when I was first
looking at this I was actually working
at Medtronic at the time which is a big
medical device company and I have family
members who were morbidly obese and
that's just to give you a sense it's
usually defined as being a hundred
pounds overweight and really saw my
family member struggling and wanted and
they were thinking about getting OBC
surgery those were things like gastric
bypass or the Lap Band it's a typically
very invasive surgeries and they're
frankly they're pretty frightening so
they didn't end up getting it because
they were scared of it and the family
was scared for them at the same time I
saw Medtronic was opening up a brand-new
of obesity division to look at less
invasive therapies and to give you a
sense of it you know Medtronic
divisions each one usually does a couple
billion dollars in revenue so when I
came I set foot on Stanford as a MBA I
immediately wanted to look into the
space and went through the Stanford
Biodesign program I used some classes at
the business school and then when I
graduated in 2007 launched this company
with
someone from the med school and a few
people from the engineering school we
raised our first round of catheter
before let's hold that for a little
later but how you did it yeah just let's
just say a little more about what you do
now so so you are an obesity company you
address that as a disease where are you
in this in the stage of delivering a
product and how are you developing that
yeah so everyone else will probably talk
about revenues revenues for us are in
the in the distant future because we
first have to get through FDA approvals
so they can give you a quick concept of
how obesity company kind of evolves
first you have to go through preclinical
trials before you can then run your run
human trials and and that's where we are
right now we're just gearing up for our
first human trials later this year and
you have to prove that your device is
safe and then and run a small trial you
know 30 patients and that in that regard
and then you'll implant your device in a
larger group of patients typically
obesity companies use about 300 patients
and then you wait for about a year and
you hope that your device helps people
lose lose you know at least 25% there
their excess weight the results though
and I've met with some of the patients
who have gone through these types of
obesity surgeries they're incredible I
mean it's you know people literally say
it's like getting their lives back in
that and that's what we're hoping to do
for patients in a much safer way they
allow them to you know drop literally 50
plus 50 to 100 pounds I met and patients
who've dropped 250 pounds and you know
ran Bay to Breakers next year
and so our company is looking to do the
the same thing but you know the way the
surgery works today is they have to make
different incisions into the person's
abdomen implant a device or they
to kind of staple staple stomachs and
the concept is if you make a patient's
stomach smaller they'll feel fuller
faster and they'll eat less we're going
to do the same thing but we can deliver
our therapies trans orally so without
any incisions without general anesthesia
will be a lot faster for physicians to
do and it'll be a lot a lot less
expensive for patients because amazingly
almost 1/3 of patients actually pay for
this procedure out of their own pocket
because they were just you know
insurance sometimes is its health care
system in the in the u.s. is very
difficult and they truly want to get
these procedures and feel better so
they're willing to pay up their own
pockets so we're looking you know twenty
twenty twelve plus time frame until
patients can eventually have our
products so you said you worked for
mechatronics but do you have a medical
background yes so as a biomedical
engineer from Duke and then went to work
in Medtronic and actually in marketing
and project management good Thank You
Brad oh yeah my name's Brad straws class
of 2002 so I don't have a bio medical
degree so I run a debt relief company um
we started our business i co-founded it
with andrew Houser who is a classmate of
mine and a good friend we actually
started it about a year after we
graduated from business school which
we'll go into in a little bit but in
some ways my experience was kind of
analogous maybe to some of you guys is
when I accepted to come to uh to
Stanford Business School Nasdaq was at
five thousand and pets.com was a big
thing and Sand Hill was like Mecca in
shortly after agreeing to come to
Stanford Nasdaq cratered in the.com
thing sort of fell apart and you were
just happy to have a job so in 2002 when
I came out I think we were the only two
people that started a company our year
and if you sort of went back to when we
joined or came to school in 2000 there
were some
like 50 companies were started so a
roomful of people is encouraging here
but we freedom Financial Network is a
five hundred and twenty five person
company that does a whole bunch of
direct-to-consumer financial services
including freedom that release freedom
tax relief a little bit in the mortgage
space and really what we kind of
innovated on and we'll get into this of
how we kind of launch the businesses we
thought the consumer finance world was
broken for people who fall out of the
current payer kind of super prime world
with a bunch of relatively poor executed
on point products and we wanted to be a
suite of services and kind of align our
interests with with the consumers and
it's been a fun and exciting ride that
we've been relatively successful and
Chuck knows our story well he's on our
board and Ben sloop from the campus of
the GSB runs consolidation plus product
force two which is I'm kind of the next
product we want you thank you so you
have an idea where these companies do
now a little bit about the individuals
we wanted it to address four questions
as I indicated and we're gonna start
this the first question with Brad and so
Brad say a little bit about what you did
while you were in school to prepare for
this either in terms of searching for
the idea or ideas trying to evaluate
ideas did you do that while you were
here or did you wait till you let you
you were ready to leave tell us a little
bit about that process yes so um we
started a year after we graduated so
really the lion's share of the work we
did was after we graduated from school
but while we were in school one sort of
critical thing for me that you know if
this resonates with you guys but I had a
tough time getting focused and sort of
discipline on working on business ideas
my second year a business school
anything Andrew did to having a
co-founder and a sounding board and an
advisor if someone sort of holds you
accountable to your ideas and your
homework project and your research on
industries and business plans was really
critical for us is we would meet weekly
and go through and give each other
homework projects you've got to do a
little PowerPoint slide on this industry
how big it is and I think if it were
just me in a vacuum I probably wouldn't
have been
is accountable to that but I ended up
Andrew turned all of his jobs down we
were private equity venture capital guys
and was really committed to the startup
model and we went through a hundred
business ideas before we ended up all
over the place from jewelry rental a
bunch of comm businesses buying a suite
of cabs in Chicago - I went to a private
equity firm that did a lot in consumer
finance and I had done a bunch in
consumer finance and investing in
collections and mortgage and we really
got just infatuated with this idea that
enormous industry fragmented weak
competition and a ton of margin in the
kind of economic rents in the value
chain and we didn't know how to crack
that nut but we just got really
committed to that was gonna be our
industry fortunately being in a private
equity firm for eight months I realized
this is not what I want to do number one
and number two I got to see a lot of
business plans and a lot of them with
high margins a directly applicable to
those verticals that we were looking at
or that kind of larger space we really
got quickly on to this idea of getting
people out of debt and the fact that you
know negative connotations and it's got
a lot of weak competition but you can't
pick a bigger I mean thirteen trillion
in consumer debt - and actually in
revolving 90 billion charges off as
uncollectible every year and essentially
no Stanford MBAs go after that space so
our eyes got big of this is a lot easier
than competing with you know but HBS and
GSB guys for the next venture deal is
let's go compete with a bunch of guys
who used to sell used cars and we'll do
a lot better job and innovate and our
innovation was to sort of have ROI based
pricing for the consumer and do real
education and budgeting and a suite of
services quit my job raise some angel
angel financing from some GSB friends
and family from the partners at the at
the venture firm I worked at and
launched with Andrew but you would you
have found this idea if you hadn't work
in private equity do you think if you
and Andrew were continuing to think
about ideas right yeah I wouldn't have
found that if I hadn't partnered with
Andrew and he wouldn't have found that
if he hadn't
with me we may have found it because one
of our classmates a guy named Kent
Steffes who you know well too he had
Bloomberg terminals in his GSB dorm room
which costs thirty thousand dollars a
year he's a guy won a gold medal in the
atlantic olympics for you know beach to
on to beach volleyball steph is karai
he's a really aggressive guy and he
negotiated himself out of thirty
thousand dollars of debt to Bloomberg
and we watched this exercise over about
six months and thought there's no way an
average person could ever go through
this agony and this guy loves it that
that kind of married with the fact and
he lived with Andrew and Jeff and it was
one of my really good friends
that combined with going out and seeing
the margins in collection agencies and
the margins in the mortgage industry and
then us we just started putting ads in
newspapers and saying we're gonna do
free consultations with people and
figure out what are your pain points
what are your needs and the whole thing
kind of coalesced that maybe we would
have but it certainly accelerated it the
fact that I was in front of a lot of
different business plans ideas economic
models and I shortened my time so Darren
what did you do while you were here
sounds to me like you found some some
people across the street as we say to to
work with how did you do that so one of
one of my deciding factors to come to
Stanford over maybe some other business
school in the East Coast was the bio
design program and it's an incredible
interdisciplinary interdisciplinary
program that brings folks together from
the business school the med school and
the engineering schools to just tackle
the biggest problems in in health and
typically utilizing medical devices like
I said I kind of had this burning desire
to work in the obesity space so the the
most important thing I think I decided
to do at Stanford was to pick the right
group of people to work with so to kind
of give an example of that at the
beginning of the course you did a poster
on like what your medical need was what
it was addressing and you tried to
attract people to your group
a lot of people came by and they kind of
saw like the space I was working on but
a couple of a few people came by
multiple times and said this is really
what I want to do this is really what I
want to work on and we're really excited
about it and I just decided to work with
those people because they genuinely
seemed really excited and you know it
couldn't have worked out better and I
think that made all the difference in
the world was getting people who were
really enthusiastic willing to stay you
know do the projects till whatever time
it took actually mr. Valentine's Day
because of it and you know that I think
the people were the the key ingredient
and the support at Stanford both the by
design I picked another great group of
classmates to work with in the
evaluating entrepreneurial opportunities
class at the business school those were
really great ways of kind of exploring
ideas and then evaluating the ideas and
then once I went through that I felt
comfortable kind of burning the bridge
and right at graduation I'm trying to go
raise capital the business idea came
between the summers of the first and
second year actually partly girls trying
to find something to live for my
housemates for the second year and
started looking around on Craigslist
over the Edelson started intrigued by
the real estate industry and it it
really sucked and so that at the end of
the second at the end of the summer I
was pretty convinced that this was a
business that was very interesting and I
had a entrepreneurial background before
I consumed internet so was felt
comfortable with the challenge ahead and
at that point it was really a case of
okay I knew I wanted to sort a business
my co-founder who's a good friend and
classmate we teamed up very very early
on and said this was the business that
we both wanted to run and at that point
is really this whole of the second it
was class was important we absolutely
wanted to graduate
but we spent every single opportunity to
get credit for thinking about this
business we could so we did the S 356
Annie Ratcliffe spending half an hour or
an hour a week with Andy every single
week for two quarters it's just
phenomenal tapping the insights and
ideas of all the professor's we could
and as you probably guess I was born in
England so I knew no one else so so I
knew no one in the u.s. really apart
from people at the GSB so the GSB was
was really my only resource for the
information other than you know cold
calling people or or getting in touch
with people so just using all the credit
so cute and good listens what about you
so I had sort of the opposite experience
of Brad I got to the GSB knowing I
wanted to be an entrepreneur but in the
first six months I got pretty involved
in the wine club wine was a hobby and a
passion and and I was pretty struck by
two things one how relatively thirsty
for a lack of a better pun the the
wineries and importers that we were
bringing in at that time for to do the
wine club I don't know what level of
intensity the wine club has here right
now at that point we were Kevin Kugler
and I were pretty intense about it we
had a few events a week and we really
were both considering entering the wine
industry and and had a quite a wonderful
array of people come in we were really
struck I was really struck by how
thirsty these wineries and importers
were to market their products to these
consumers and I was also struck by how
relatively well traveled extremely well
educated our peers are at the GSB how
people were pretty intimidated by wine
so I didn't portend to have all the
answers but I certainly felt empowered
to find out information and and get
people to help guide us into and through
the world of wine and so the idea that
notion of providing some sort of guiding
function for consumers into the world of
wine was something that started a gel
for me really early in my first year and
like all of these people I was pretty
shameless about using my time here
to to help in that regard I wrote a case
for gin wing it's that he teaches still
on new vine logistics our back-end
logistics management firm that we use to
distribute wine throughout 25 out of the
50 states I wrote that case while here
they're now our partner for that did a
market research project with Michaela
dragon schoo who's on sabbatical this
year but on our advisory board Jim
Latins doing a you know did project with
him in his marketing class digging into
some of the matching actually a 390 with
him on on the matching piece and
personal taste profiles and he's doing a
sales a little module on bottle notes
right now I actually see some familiar
faces in the audience looking into some
ideas and how we can increase sales
through our registry so I've we've been
undercapitalized from day one something
I strongly would discourage but it's
also been only because of the
extraordinary resources during the GSB
that we were able to put all the pieces
together and since that you know through
some ESP summer interns and and great
advisory board members and the like that
it's been and classmates on the advisory
board as well that we've been able to
get as far as we have on such relative
economic fumes in terms of in terms of
actually the business plan it was an
evolutionary process during my time here
I to actually like Brad had a classmate
that I worked on it with she knew from
pretty early on she wanted to go into
venture so she was more of a thought
partner and and we had those weekly
meetings where you grab a room and the
library and your whiteboard where you're
going next but she was great and has
found her shares and all that good
friend but when it came time to actually
take the plunge I ended up relatively
speaking taking it alone
I ended up pulling in a close friend
who's 10 years my senior but had her own
business for 10 years in New York also a
Yale grad who had been in the wine world
and I ended up pulling her in as a
director of his dev co-founder /
director biz dev so I do concur that it
is much much much nicer to take the
plunge
jump off the proverbial cliff with a
partner our partnership is not one of
equals incidentally in time equity cash
invested all that but but it absolutely
is something that I have nonetheless
really benefited from so all and those
relationships solidified that
relationship was one that was actually
formed through a mutual
at the GSB so you you've all said a
little bit about what you did the GSB
and you've said a little bit about the
classmates but let me start with you
Pete because you said that basically be
from England what you had here was the
GSB and that was about it but as you as
you started the company and you moved
out what other resources in the
community did you find helpful how did
you put together your business plan did
you how did you find your your legal
firm how did you begin to attract those
resources so primarily networking and
you know it's really using the resources
so just that's a couple of examples so
at first so yeah when to get a prototype
done we went over to I don't know if it
still runs but there's a there's a group
of student student student enterprises
or something that they do some basic
they did some basic coding on so so
anyway the we paid some student and some
engineering students to build some
prototypes we ended up hiring the guy
that did the prototypes for us
this is graduating we legal counsel
there was David Hornick he was a
teaching intellectual poverty class he
was next lawyer who was a professor he
introduced us to three or four legal
firms we we pick one of them I spent the
summer and the end of my second year at
the CES kind of camped out there we
linndrum the gang using all the
resources we didn't have an office and
until we had that so using pretty much
all the resources we had one of the one
of the other things that we did was in
the early stages we would do market
research we it's much easier to pick up
the phone and say you're a Stanford
Business School student then it is you
are Joe Blow calm real estate site
because they don't know whether you're a
competitor they don't know who you are
and they a lot of people think of
spending time with students is kind of
intellectual philanthropy and so you can
spend time with people and you can pick
their brains and their
it was amazing how much time we got and
how open people were sometimes
competitive potential compares were
maybe too open but we were always very
honest about kind of our intentions and
you know that we were thinking of
starting a business but we were students
and we were doing some market research
we got so much so much achieved by by
putting ourselves with Stanford students
well so you're shaking your head so you
do the same things still do the same
thing have you know really great student
projects happening and have for a long
time and totally honest and but you know
had a summer intern this last summer
look into our international strategy cuz
the firm in Dubai was really interested
in participating and I said I know
nothing about that the wine world in
that market and have at it so I think
the the notion of being a student of any
topic or industry is something as
literal students or as interns is a
really great resource to leverage out of
the GSB but you know I the GSB is just I
mean why we all chosen why we're all
probably in this room right now is just
one of the richest entrepreneurial
places in the country if not the world
and you know from lawyer found sitting
in Bishop when Allison Tilly of
Pillsbury came walking through and she
was willing to do all the setup work for
the corporation without us paying for it
until the time of the first financing or
you know in the liske in and the first
service provider blended itself to other
service providers accountants and all
the rest I mean the list that that's one
example the list goes on and on and on
and and not just Stanford not just you
know being a student in getting people
come through here but even since we have
an entrepreneurial listserv for our
class and I mean the amount of
forwarding and recommending of next
hires or or service providers or you
name it that comes through that it's
it's sort of once someone gives it a
high once a classmate or or a fellow
alumni gives it a stamp of approval
bookkeeping my bookkeeper has been
farmed out I think too for other GSB
businesses so I mean it you know it just
it's a really rich network and it's
fortunate and just one on the I own
Brad was sitting up here three or four
years ago and I came and grabbed Brad
afterwards and said hey Brett I've got
this idea about where to say can we all
have a coffee
you got gave up his time I Germans
haven't seen you since but it's kind of
funny how well what are these you're
hearing here is how generous the alumni
are they it's an incredible group and
part of it is the reason they're all
here today helping you and you just
heard that there'd be happy if you grab
them afterwards so Darren it's not the
financing resources yet but just other
resources at Stanford not yours not your
classmates and as you started moving out
in this I mean obviously the professor's
are pretty good here now the I mean
what's incredible is that to realize
that a lot of the professor's here just
so well connected with the UH with the
Sand Hill Road crew with industry
thought leaders around the world and and
a lot of them were practitioners who
have just had the experiences of been
there done that so I still go to to one
of my professors on almost a quarterly
basis looking for advice sometimes
looking for some financial resources but
I mean I don't think there's a VC that
that this individual doesn't know and
they're so incredibly giving of their
time I mean the fact that they're here
teaching it's I mean obviously they want
to give back to back to the students so
I think just as giving us the alumni our
I mean the professor's are equally so
rad what about you yeah just like you
know like oh all of that a cold intro
saying you're a Stanford Business School
student to someone who's never met you
before it's a very powerful thing
shockingly I mean a lot of people return
your calls the alumni network even cold
is a very powerful thing to this day I
get calls it's I went to a small college
to Amherst College where I'm very happy
to return those calls and I get
solicited
dozens of times a day it's a Stanford
thing people are pretty loyal to the
other is warm intros we've gotten
introduced to Chuck's on our board you
know a bunch of professors here have
been really invaluable to us CEO of you
know Wells Fargo Capital One senators
and they don't do it because they're
doing I mean I think it's there's a
positive selection bias to professor's
here that they want to see you succeed
and they want to go out of the way to
help you that is for us has been very
powerful tactically we have a GSB guy
from 93 or 94 Ariel Polar's on our board
who's a serial entrepreneur and very
successful almost everything he touches
that's a very powerful thing down in
your board because then you don't have
to waste time vetting accounting firms
and tax firms and just tactical things a
guy who's seen five companies succeed he
just says here's the one to pick here's
the partner to go with here's the intro
to this firm and you trust that resource
and it's I'd say from a board level
really really valuable
one last thing tactically that kind of P
was talking about chatting with
competitors but I don't know if you guys
have Careerbuilder or hot jobs or
monster through the CES you can call
almost anyone and say you're thinking
about you're interviewing people for
whatever role you make up what that role
is when you're in Business School and
you're launching a company they will
talk endlessly about anything you want
to talk about and you get a lot of very
valuable information under the pretense
of I'm interviewing you we actually
ended up hiring some of those people
that in our sort of first year when we
were essentially business planning and
using those people as to fill out the
white board of what the economic model
looks like we ended up hiring some of
those people but we also got a ton of
very good intelligence out of interviews
it turns out that most people who have
done something that's good know what
they're proud of it and would love to
tell you about it and so that's that's
an important thing to realize Taryn so
let's talk about financing and you start
us off what did you do when you realize
you had 12 years to go on this before
you saw any revenue and maybe not that
but six at least
there's a very big black hole of capital
that capital is going to need to fill at
the time so you know kind of laid out
the plan and realized that this was this
project was gonna take 50 to 60 million
dollars to get to profitability on so
but what I didn't like have a great
appreciation for was spending that first
million would actually be the most
important money spent on the project and
you know I guess it's you you can't
really talk about financing without
talking about milestones and that was
something that was totally lost on me
upon graduation also I thought okay I'm
going to I have to I don't have to do
preclinical trials and go into human
trials I need to get a proof of concept
would take it took some of my
competitors you know a minimum of three
to five million dollars so I thought
okay I'll go and raise three to five
million dollars but and looking at that
number I realized well it's too big for
angels it probably it probably need to
be venture capital that totally went
vast laid back and forth because I
started doing some really incredible
people other entrepreneurs who had been
in a similar situation and I can't lie I
can't recommend it enough talking to
people who have been in your shoes
before who have especially on similar
type projects because he said no you
don't need five million dollars you need
a half a million dollars and I thought
he was crazy and then I realized that he
wasn't and there is ways to take out
make shorter term milestones because
it's really hard at school to to get
people to shell out millions of dollars
when you don't have this long track
record it's much easier when you're
saying well here's I want to do a half a
million dollars here's exactly how I'm
going to spend it and then build up your
track record and then now that you have
this track record that you do what you
say you're going to do it makes it so
much easier to raise subsequent capital
so you know half a million dollars I
thought that was an angel more of an
angel play so I started talking to
angels for a while and by the way that
the moral of the story is definitely
leave yourself like at least nine months
of cash that you know you can live on
before you really have to raise capital
because it takes a while to do it right
out of school so and I talked to
classmates before and it takes almost
everybody about you know February March
timeframe that's when they get their
capital so went to the Angels started
talking to angels it's amazing there are
people here that you talk with them they
afterwards are like well should I say
email you the $50,000 check or do you
like why I put into the bank I mean they
serial entrepreneurs in the valley are
mind boggling
so I actually been that you guys can all
get access to it yeah I mean I don't
think you'd get a meeting with a lot of
those guys dead serious without you know
maybe an intro or you say on the
Stanford Business School guy I'm
starting to company a lot of people will
sit down with you this is that
absolutely true and was looking at
angels and then also in a small seed
stage VC got very interested and was
able to actually blend the two and have
like the VC lead the round and angels
kind of come in later which worked out
really nicely because the the VC took
the responsibility of sitting on the
board and it allowed the angels to be a
little bit more passive but feel very
comfortable that there was someone very
actively monitoring the business so that
does to see that was the early stage and
now you know we're doing or follow-on
follow-on round right now so Pete you
had been involved in an entrepreneurial
activity before then you started this
company as you said not exactly markets
haven't been exactly kind to you real
estate markets so what's been your
experience in raising money first the
first money and then the follow-on money
if there has been so I guess like
contrasting to Brad in 2005 in 2006 when
we did an initial fundraising really
proof-of-concept fundraising it was
relatively easy compared to 2002 so I
think you know in compared to today so I
think we we certainly work were quite
lucky with the timing maybe just a
couple of
perspectives from that process we
thought it'd be really cool to get a
big-name BC before we launched but it's
practically impossible
and we spent far too much time with big
VCS and it's probably not the right
thing to do anyway to raise a lot of
money without having launched so we
wasted too much time with with big-name
B C's early on but that said it's useful
to spend time with super smart people
who understand the space and can follow
you and track you and all the people
that turn us down in the early stages
ended up investing in later stages after
it hit hit some milestones secondly we
you know as a web company and as a
product company showing someone a
fantastic business plan or spreadsheet
or model or market analysis only this is
is 10% of the exercise we found our
conversion rates of raising money was
was substantially improves when we
improved when we had a really cool
website the people could look at and
play with them thought oh this is
awesome I get it so you know however
good your
market analysis isn't however much it
passes the
the test of the professor's the product
if you've got a product spend more time
we're getting a cool product a useful
product a part of the resonates and your
conversion to raising capital would
substantially increase well so have you
gone for subsequent rounds yes we raised
kind of a seed angel round so the first
a person master was met by we met a guy
called having Kevin Hartz through the
Entrepreneurship Club at the GSB a
networking dinner or something so that
was our first semester the guy that led
a series a GSB guy called Greg waddle
four runs eHarmony
he's on our board intro'd from Gathol
owner and someone else and
and saris beep Excel she's it's
frightening new GSP it spills to club'
feels like some of there's some mafia
thing going on their board is mostly GSP
but you know that's the power of the
network so you know those and those
connections were primarily driven out of
GSP connections having a prototype I
think is huge I think it carries from
websites to medical devices to anything
another entrepreneur once told me that
investors are very smart but often lack
imagination and having a prototype kind
of just allows them to really see and
feel or or understand exactly how it's
supposed to work and so I know it's a
valuable for for raising capital you
know it's also kind of funny I feel like
you know you're ready to have capital
when you suddenly feel like you don't
really need it because you've somehow
struggled and gotten to to improve
something that you never thought would
be possible without having money first
and then you get there and you're like
you know I didn't even need the capital
I won't even take people's money but and
that's when people typically are like
well we're ready to give you money
listen I think thinking about what these
guys were saying in terms of the
prototype versus not I think in terms of
the the lifecycle of being an
entrepreneur I think the first time
you're out of the gate you're freshly
minted MBA you know from the GSB no less
you're selling sizzle and a sexy
PowerPoint deck and maybe a fancy model
- and of course yourself I think that
actually and other people have done this
very well just raising more initially on
the promise of tomorrow more than you'll
need is a prototype in hand or not is I
think the world's best advice for
entrepreneurship and I think that once
you launch you know a beta site a real
site a product in current of clinical
trial something consumers are using or
not all of a sudden the clock starts
ticking on milestones that are unless
it's the medical
space of the dollars in users and
consumer traction kind so it's something
to be mindful of if you're raising I
think raising initially makes more an
upfront is something I would do
differently the next time but my story
is fairly similar to these guys I ended
up doing a friends-and-family Marilyn of
about a million dollars follow notes is
totally capitalized by high net worth
individuals to date we've raised three
and a half million which as Darren
mentioned is quite a lot for high nets
it's been quite a labor of love it's a
lot for angel investors at fifty two
hundred thousand dollars a check our
average unit is higher than most it's
around two hundred thousand so it hasn't
been quite as onerous in that regard but
the first the first person who gave me
the green light which was in May of
before graduation was classmates father
that I had worked for the prior summer
for his boutique import company of wine
so that and you know the conversation
was would you like to come run this
import company and the answer was no but
I think for the same amount you know
because I think for the same how you pay
me for the next few years if you invest
at that seed capital in this venture
right here's how the ROI would be
different for for the three brands or
five brands I'd be managing anyway and
that's how that whole thing kicked off
and then it was a series of
relationships personal from Chicago my
business partners in New York and other
GSB one step removed type of things
that's how we raise the capital then and
since and in terms of fundraising it has
we've done two rounds we are about four
weeks away from closing our second and
again I think that you know who we've
attracted Evan but as investors has
absolutely as Darren mentioned been tied
to milestones but also strategy so when
we were in Ishii commerce play we were
picking a high net worth individuals who
for whom wine was a serious passion
project huge sellers they loved one they
love wine travel as you morph and as our
strategy is more now the investors
coming to the table are people who buy
into and get this notion of a premier
online wine community they've invested
in other media assets they've been early
folks at Google whatever the case may be
so at risk of you know stating the
obvious
you know the aligning the strategy with
from a high net worth individual
standpoint or even a venture funds
and point I mean strategically if if
someone's making you throw on your
behalf they're obviously going to make
the connection of why it's relevant but
just even when you're doing your initial
research of who you'd reach out to would
it be Greg Waldorf or someone else for
example in Pete's case you know
obviously people with who have who have
experience in akin industries or
complementary products is something that
seemed to work for me bread you know a
little different company you people
intensive you've had to grow very
rapidly
tell us about your financing strategy so
we um we bootstrapped our business we've
never raised traditional outside
institutional money we did sort of a
clever thing intranet kind of
bootstrapped it for about a hundred
thousand dollars ourselves and we didn't
have to wait six years for revenue so we
started raising money in aggregate we
raised less than a million dollars from
angels which was surprisingly easy to
come up with echo one point ELISA made
is if someone doesn't contribute value
to your organization as an investor if
they don't add some facet of your
business that that you don't have you
really don't want them as investors the
other thing is early on the guys who put
$10,000 into our business we're way more
of a nuisance than the people that put
$200,000 into our business and got it so
that's one little aside just tactically
how we did it though then we started
raising essentially a bridge round that
stayed open open open open open until we
closed our bridge round which converted
to the valuation what that let us do is
have a lot of milestones for a very long
runway when we closed our closed door
round you know minimize dilution for us
so we and it fits into sort of our whole
strategy is we didn't want to be driven
to an exit we wanted to be driven to
create long term great business that you
know someday will be hopefully in the
capital one or very large business of
kind of underserved consumers and we
really did think one for dilution two
for control and three to be driven to a
short-term exit it didn't sort of match
up with with what our vision was for the
business so what we also did one of the
kind of interesting thing which is the
the model when we first started was this
is way more detailing you guys are gonna
want but we would charge someone 25% of
we saved them that was this ROI based
pricing we realized were broke and we
need to hire people and so the early
hires we paid them nothing literally
nothing and we gave them some at code
when we said we hope we'll be able to
pay you in the future and people trusted
us and came on board John Helen who to
this day is our EVP of operations all of
our early hires are still to this day
with us we've been very fair of them
over the long term the other thing we
did is we went to we realized can we
switch our economic model to force our
customers to finance our growth and we
figured out a way to charge them earlier
in the process and by signing up more
customers bizarrely it started becoming
a positive working capital business that
then we didn't have to raise much more
money again minimize dilution we didn't
have to concede control and it let us
pick board of directors who we really
love and trust and and appreciate our
vision and not a guy who has you know
voting control and tells us what we can
and can't do great so I want to turn
open to questions for the audience now
you can ask general questions or ask
them a specific individual really
quickly can I just say don't put on this
financing thing I owe Pete will will
resent me now but we've been into
Sequoia many times we get cold called a
fair amount but they did a brilliant
study that I love and hopefully Alissa
is gonna love this is they did a
regression and correlated their biggest
returns over history with the amount of
capital raised and when I was in
business school this thing or her right
before of raising two hundred million
dollars for comm was like the big thing
right they realized that the businesses
that essentially bootstrap - were very
lean on capital and were very efficient
with capital were huge - the skew of
several standard deviations over to the
success in the return we think for us
one thing that that's taught us is
capital efficiency also it forces
operational discipline and you can't
band-aid over operational problems or
strategic problems or marketplace
problems with money by hiring or
throwing dollars at at it you got to fix
fundamentally an issue when you're cheap
and scrappy and small for us I think
that's a you know it's easier to raise
money and hire but if you're willing to
work hard and roll up your sleeves I
think long-term it's kind of a for us
it's been a cool thing I wanted to add
to that that there's a venture fund of
Altos ventures in town
there at all GSP guys and they invested
in one of our classmates no I did a
reference for them and I was really just
poking around their site in their
strategy and they will only invest in
companies now that are raising less than
five million total to get to break-even
not just cuz the climate they were ahead
of the curve therefore that it be cut
based on that exact same study so I
think that's heartening not that there
aren't zillions of stories Netflix and
others of raising 110 and turning or
Zappos and you name it at that it we're
raising a lot works and I have complete
confidence and truly it will make it
happen even you know what 33 million in
the bank but I absolutely can say that
the only other caution of of being not
necessarily in Brad's case where you're
hitting that breakeven point early
enough and it's a positive cash flow
situation where you can grow the
business organically and my case which
is hybrid consumer technology things
you've still got some major technology
expenses which requires a bunch of labor
and people which is capital intensive
but also revenues so where where do you
you know first of all raising enough to
get to that point even if it's not a lot
it's so critical but also I think one of
the big fears and raising having a
totally angel back business as brad has
also already alluded to is not
necessarily getting the panache or even
the expertise of phenomenal board
members and I have found that to be
absolutely not the case one of the best
pieces of advice I got from a VC friend
when I was starting this knowing I
wasn't going the VC route was if you
want to build you know a fortune 500
companies so to speak start with a
fortune 500 board so you know asked the
guy who founded Netflix to be on the
board and asked one of the founders not
read but one of the founding team
members and asked Jack Hayford who's one
of the founders and fathers of Napa
Valley and since then we've taken on the
CEO of Encyclopedia Brittanica former
CEO of that as well and so you know I
think that akin to what we were saying
in the beginning that people are willing
to invest in you as entrepreneurs they
want to see you succeed particularly if
they have a connection to the GSB I
think the same is also true of other
entrepreneurs GSB or otherwise that you
know another classmate of ours
Kirk Hawkins as in a phenomenal company
called Icahn aircraft and you know
someone said to him who do you want
would be your dream board member
you know in your business plan and a
bunch of ideas and he said this guy and
called up the guy and got him and and
people want to people want to see you
win and by and large I think that even
if you're not venture backed you can
really put together a phenomenal board
which I have found extremely beneficial
and useful as stewards of the business
by raising money and being frugal or not
much good when I come to office in the
Mission Possible home just go on the
doorstep it's a very important lesson to
be frugal with money and I think if you
look at the people who have grown big
companies they they'll all tell you they
all tell you that that doesn't mean you
don't need any money just means he has
to be frugal with it
there was a question out here so let me
see if I can repeat the question so the
question is how do you gain credibility
early on is that right when you go out
of when you come out of Business School
is it we've talked about a prototype
they talked about hitting milestones and
you're suggesting maybe there's some
other way that you gain credibility is
that right so how are you going to sell
yourself to to an angel or a VC if you
have no experience doing this so who
wants to take that one clarification
selling to VCS and selling to angels are
two very different processes theses are
all about measurable returns in their
pockets angels they want to return but a
lot of that return is sometimes
psychological whereas
in sometimes I guess as Alissa said you
know they're very passionate about the
industry that or the the concept that
you're working on and they want to help
you with that and so they're willing to
kind of kick in the money even on the
earlier side when it's really risky and
the returns to their wallet aren't
aren't you know in sight but in terms of
how to shore up credibility I think you
know an advisory board is an
extraordinarily important tool at least
it was for me I mean just having an
advisory board of really deep industry
expertise coming out of the GSB 26 never
read a cup you know had been in politics
never been in business level and start a
company you know having this bench of
people who wanted to see us win and
founder of Christie's wine department
but you know Pete Mondavi jr. who's the
GSP guy Jack Cakebread I mean all these
people plus other oh and if you you know
all stars in and from the technology
world people who are who want to see you
win and so it's it's a likes attract
likes thing right I mean if they see
these people who are obvious success
stories surrounding you and advising you
and coaching you then all of a sudden
the risk is somewhat by no means all the
way but somewhat mitigated
and then the two other things one is PR
and if you obviously is more difficult
if you were pre launch and then secondly
is just knowing your stuff if you spend
six months know your industry speaking
to customers know your stuff and be
prepared to answer every question in
detail then then that is more
credibility than anything else to that
and if there's one venture guy that you
have to have on I wouldn't go to that
person first you go to that person last
once you've got it really dialed in
organization what are some positives
negatives with your age I'm sure that
becomes an issue you deal with people on
a personal level as uncredible so the
question is once you start running a
business what are the positives and
negatives about being young yeah I'm
walking to VCS and they'd be like oh you
went to Duke you know maybe you know the
such-and-such and then they feel like
well what you do you graduate oh three
oh you're a kid you know it's at the
it's really interesting that if you do
as you know Pete was saying if you know
your stuff and you and you can really
speak to the speak to the industry speak
to your customers understand your
competitors where their failed where
their opportunities and you you do you
say you're going to set out to do
something and then you hit that you know
that's what builds respect and they you
know in you know mmm like in my
particular case I was talking I was
trying to listen was saying and get some
great advisors on board and these
advisors are saying you're crazy like I
spent three years of my life trying to
do this couldn't do it it's impossible
and had to go and do six months and
figure out how to get the preclinical
model working and then once we did the
next week you said this is amazing I
can't believe you did it I'm on board
so I think results speak much louder
than age or anything else
well maybe the question also had to do
about running the organization not just
raising the money he said right yeah
sort of operating you've got your money
and now you're trying to deal with
partners suppliers and importantly
employees we just grabbed
one of the top people from one of our
competitors and it was based on our
results of the business and this
person's you know what's twice my age so
Brad you probably have more people in
your company another so what what about
that aspect of it yeah I don't know I
don't I don't um I'm not the right
person I don't think about this I really
it doesn't even I don't know I don't
even process the thought I think you
outwork people you're in their respect
you have success they trust you shared
values I think age maybe it's something
when someone meets you for 10 seconds
that they they deal with I don't think
it's there you know our CFO Rich's he
was GSB 73 brilliant guy he's like a
good friend of mine you know we get to
dinner it goes away very quickly when
you're in sitting in business school it
probably feels a little less tangible
and real when you get out and you're
working in a team age is not a it's not
a factor but work ethic is I mean I
think as at the helm of any organization
at any age we're youth is a obvious
advantage in terms of energy and stamina
of course I mean I have I am the first
person on email I'll be the last person
at the end of every single day I I don't
know how you are in respect of anyone of
any age working for you or with you and
without out working them because they're
buying into a vision and a dream at
least initially that you're putting
forth so if you aren't zealous in your
pursuit of it how how does you have to
be doing still confidence but you want
to be if you're really passionate about
it but I mean I also think that there's
the other side of age right I mean I
don't really don't say this to be self
promoting but I was in Inc magazines 30
under 30 this year and it got a lot of
attention I made it by like you under
the wire by a week it was it was great
and I think there's a notion of if
you're a hotshot like Darren and you're
right out of school and you've got this
great medical device and you can get it
done in six months and they couldn't get
it done in three years and you're young
and you're hungry and look at Zuckerberg
at Facebook I mean it youth is an
advantage make no mistake about it it's
just a question I mean all the other
obvious things about managing the
organization I totally agree in terms
about working people to me that's and
and just general maturity employees I
think are how you combat it you're
probably gonna get some selection bias
too
an issue for somebody they won't work
for that's fine you don't want right
here that's sure I got that okay it's
your personal leverage so you needed an
income so it wouldn't worked for us we
were we were both very fortunate that we
didn't have student loans when we came
out partly if the jobs we had going into
school and we'd we'd both in our year
you would worked for five years before
you get into business school I think
that's changed a little bit now you
raise money probably you know it lets
you pay your salary you know that's
that's that's the expectation probably
not a you know not a lot but let's you
pay salary but our business we didn't
pay ourselves for three years two years
we paid also zero
third year we paid ourselves $36,000 a
year if we had student debt we couldn't
have done it how do you raise money more
money than you need and still maintain
credibility yeah listen I think you're
the one who said that there are many
things I have going for me that being
over capitalized is not one of them I'm
great when you are when you are high net
worth individual backed and it's the
nuclear winter of the eck capital equity
markets and it's a tough time of the
money we've raised the way you do it is
you create a market like an anything in
life so what happens is when you're
fundraising is that you are talking to a
large universe of people and I think
this is true for angels and VCs but the
but Peter Darren can speak more with
more expertise there you're talking to a
large universe of people and you're
raising a million or in this case three
and when you're raising three million
dollars you're talking you know in terms
of conversion rates you're talking to if
you're raising a million dollars you're
talking to a hundred people and you hope
that ten
for $100,000 each so as you get close as
you've got six and $700,000 committed
what you do is to all those maybes and
hopefully you know there are more than
three maybes left hopefully there are 13
maybes left you go to all of them and
you say you're raising a million and you
get 20 people who are maybe interested
and you hopefully can $400,000 each and
you hopefully close 12 or 13 of them so
basically what it means is that you just
oversubscribed around and success breeds
success and you know and that's simply
the answer I mean you just it's
authentic because what you need to get
there is still the eight hundred eight
hundred fifty thousand dollars you said
you need to get there with a 150
thousand dollar buffer but if these last
people in the last two weeks before the
deal closes just have to be in the deal
and it's just gonna give you a little
more buffer and yes is an entrepreneur
you're gonna take a little hit in terms
of equity but for that buffer it's a no
brainer to me like raising money more
money than you think you need I don't
think that is negatively related with
like a credibility credibility so I
think I think you just need to be
conservative and frugal and and you know
we weren't we always raised our money
with the expectation never being able to
raise any more money ever again
and you know as you raise the money we
plan a business to say well this is the
my last money we will need and so we
staggered our business planners we've
made certain hit certain milestones we
saw a bigger opportunity we raised more
money accordingly so raising money I
think and everyone says just raise more
money than you need and when someone's
give you money take it I followed that
advice there are a few tricks though
that you can use I know a lot of
entrepreneurs do use for kind of
explaining why additional funds are
necessary so one and kind of learned
this in Medtronic is you buffer you know
the costs of certain some big-ticket
items because you know things happen
and sometimes vendors will will like
also a new price increase effective
January 1st and it's 10 percent or 25
percent more and if that's a 30% you
know line item for you in your budget I
mean you're gonna be really glad that he
buffered that and if he didn't well that
just extends your runway a bit and and
that kind of leads to the second thing
you can do and and often investors want
to hear is that you're leaving
additional funds for one runway because
it always takes more time than you think
it's going to take to raise the next
round of capital and so they always want
to see you know at least three months of
runway sometimes you know six months and
your burn rate does not never goes down
so you know you're just forecasting your
burn rate out and you realize you're
going to need you know three to six
months of additional cash so it's not
the money that you just need to eat your
milestone it's its money to last you to
the next round I think want to make this
the last question right back there if
you could describe the Eureka moment so
great uncertainty when you're trying to
start a new business and is there was
there a Eureka moment when you decided
that you could really do this I think I
went through my my experience a little
bit the Eureka moment was a bunch of
market analysis combined with seeing
tangibly a friend doing this let me just
even put that aside for a second I think
so I had a slightly different experience
I took a job after school doing private
equity getting paid very well I was so
unfulfilled and being in the GSB it's
sort of a selfish thing that you get the
sense of entitlement of you can do
anything and you get access to these
great cases and great people don't ever
lose that and you guys are maybe peaking
at that moment in your professional
careers right now frankly that's a
really unique time to go out and get it
and do things and be very adventurous
and entrepreneurial the risk of never
doing it is very high the risk of you
not doing it in failing guess what
you're still a really smart person with
you know probably a great undergrad
degree great Network
GSP degree anyone's gonna hire you in
the future maybe any other than this
year Gus but you know the risk is not
that high I would posit the risk of not
doing it taking a job getting carry for
a venture firm five years later it gets
harder to leave ten years later harder
to leave I have so many classmates that
look at me now and say god damn it why
didn't you push me off the ledge and
tell me to start a company in 2002 I I
have kids I've been a mortgage I make
just enough money where I can't ever
justify leaving again I think that risk
is very high anybody else have an answer
to that when it happens but at the same
time every business starts somewhere and
ends up somewhere else so just don't be
be bloody-minded enough to follow your
vision but don't be so blinkered not to
be open to new opportunities because
your business will 99% certainty be
somewhere else than you thought it would
be originally recognize there may be
more than one you Rica moment huh the
notion I have a brother who's an actor
in Broadway in film and he people ask
him all the time how'd you know you
should be an actor with all the starving
artist stuff and he said when you you
know you can't do you can't not do it
and I think that that's both true for
the idea but also just as an
entrepreneur I mean there are millions
ideas as entrepreneurs that swim through
your mind as I'm sure you guys already
know on a daily basis and so that one
idea is a combination of passion and
market timing and all about other stuff
but how do you know if you're an
entrepreneur either you probably take a
job and you feel unfulfilled or you just
know you can't you're fundamentally
unemployable as the joke goes or you you
just cannot not do it you can't not be
going Mach 10 with your hair on fire
with the pit in your stomach the fear
and the excitement and the enthusiasm
and the the energy and the dream I mean
you can't not do it
that's I think the and if you cannot do
it then seriously think about it cuz
it's fun and it's hard but in this
economy why wouldn't you do it
fundamental difference between the need
that you want to solve and then the
solution so as Brad was saying like he
found this really interesting industry
you know with the consumer credit and
you know there was obviously a
fundamental need there that he saw at
first and then he had to figure out well
what's the concept like what's the best
way of running the business model to
solve that and went through customer
interviews and I think it's you know
really important to understand that
there's a need that needs to be solved
and that it's worth solving and then
then the second part comes where the
with the ideation and you can actually
do a process of brainstorming and trying
to get to that solution and I spent six
months with my team looking for that
solution frame storming our whiteboards
like calling ideas asking advisers on
which ideas they thought would work and
the end none of them were good it was
completely worthless I I thought first
and then someone was went to the meat
market one day and picked up you know
something and you know started playing
with it and we were just talking in a
group and you know what it just happened
to form the right shape in his hands and
your toes Eureka was like a company
sometimes that can really just happen
but I really think it was because we
we've gone through literally hundreds of
ideas we were able to spot you know the
one you know incidental you know moment
that that something actually came
together that sounds like a good Eureka
moment to end on Thank You Brad Darren
Pete and Alyssa appreciate your time